every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet you'd
be fine without hello everybody welcome
to the minimalists podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm sitting in
a booth by myself today well not really
about myself Sean is here our fearless
producer and Ryan is in a separate booth
I'll talk about that here in a second
and exactly what we're doing in two
separate recording studios right now but
we have some really exciting news for
you our documentary which is called
minimalism
a documentary about the important things
just came out in theatres May 24th so a
week ago from this recording and hit
number one in theaters the number one
documentary of 2016 in terms of
theatrical box office openings and I
just want to say thank you we are so
grateful we've worked really hard over
the last three years
really curating the most beautiful film
that we could make and special thanks to
Matt Diavel the director of the film and
of course the folks over aspire media
who helped us put this film together
we're finally getting this out in the
world we're so excited and when I first
got the email from our distributor I
couldn't believe when it said that it
was the number-one documentary of 2016
so far so thank you so much for that a
lot of great reviews for the film have
come in and in fact we're doing a
special episode of the minimalist
podcast today some friends of ours
Jessica Lynn Williams and a gal named
Melissa
they run a podcast called the mind
Palace and so Jessica actually works
with us she helps us out with a lot of
the the social media stuff we do over at
Facebook and Twitter and her and Melissa
just sit down once a week and have these
amazing conversations about living a
well curated life and when people often
ask us what our other minimalist podcast
you recommend that is that tends to be
the first podcast I recommend well they
sat down and had a discussion about the
film and and they tend to stray from the
film quite a bit and all of their
discussions are great
encourage you to check out their their
podcast over on iTunes or wherever you
listen to podcast but we're gonna give
you today the conversation they had last
week when the film came out about the
film if you are looking for some other
solid reviews as well you can go to the
Boston Globe or Washington Post or
Toronto Star and Chicago Tribune also
did a review of the film we'll put links
to those in our show notes if you want
to check those out also we're gonna end
today's episode after you hear from Jess
and Melissa there'll be a a track from
the soundtrack of the documentary so a
friend of mine who wasn't always a
friend of mine a guy named Andrew
Clifford kapner and well he's the the
lead singer of my favorite band a band
called parlor Hawk and they're from Utah
and I knew I wanted him to make the
music for this documentary so I reached
out to him and begged him for about six
months to to work on on the film he
eventually said yes and he teamed up
with this grammy-nominated producer
named Nate Peiffer and together they
formed a band just for this soundtrack
to the film and the band is called we
which is spelled vve and they just put
the entire soundtrack up on Spotify and
Apple music and Google Play and probably
some other places as well we'll put that
in the show notes for you too but we'll
also in this episode the very end here
with another song from the soundtrack if
you listen to it to last week's episode
of the podcast you got a sample of one
of the other tracks we'll put a
different one at the end of this episode
and I hope you get a chance to check out
all those songs it just makes the whole
movie so much better and an emotional it
really brings out the the emotion and
the film and so I'm really really
grateful that they were able to put this
music behind a message we really believe
in Ryan and I are right now in Canada
we're both in separate recording booths
here in Toronto we're at the CBC
recording back to back to back
interviews for the CBC radio stations
and I think every province up here and
and I just had a quick break and so Sean
and I are tucked away in a and a mic
booth right now with a little digital
portable recorder to record this intro
so Ryan and I will be at the premiere
the Canadian for me
of minimalism at the Bloor Theatre in
Toronto on June first Wednesday June 1st
now that's been sold out for a while but
the good news is there will be some
tickets at the door that's the very last
stop of our tour now we wanted to bring
it up here to Canada but it will also be
in Canadian theaters starting June 8th
and of course in the United States the
film is still playing in some theaters
throughout the throughout the entire
summer you can find your nearest theater
or request a screening in your town at
minimalism film calm or you can also
pre-order the film online especially if
you're not in the United States don't
worry the film still coming to you it's
going to be available worldwide online
including six hours of bonus content so
we went out and we got about a thousand
hours of footage more than a thousand
hours of footage we were making this
documentary but we obviously couldn't
fit all of that into a 79 minute movie
but there are a bunch of amazing
interviews we just couldn't include but
we still wanted you to have access to so
if you want to preorder the film you can
go to the minimalists comm a slash order
you can find all the details there we'll
put that in the show notes as well and
now I hope you enjoy this episode from
Jess and Melissa of the mind palace oh
and by the way there are some curse
words in this episode so if you have
kids in the car you may want to skip
this one for a while enjoy hello
everyone thank you for listening to the
mind Palace podcast you are here with
Melissa key in the northeast of England
and Jessica Lynn Williams from Maui
Hawaii this is a weekly podcast which
explores what it means to live a world
created life happy minimalism film day
it should be a new holiday I know it
should be a new holiday at the time of
this recording the minimalism film is
coming out today May 24th so I guess the
first screening is probably happening in
just a few hours in New York City and
then it will be showing across theaters
across the United States in Canada and
then and we also have the the film
available for pre-order on Vimeo this is
so exciting like I feel like we've been
talking about this like
even getting ready for this day for a
long time and it's finally coming to
fruition it's so crazy oh it's so
exciting like this is like the second
time I've watched and it's just it's
such an incredibly genuine later human
ray it's amazing yeah I think that's I
think like one thing that I can like I
have to say like overall for the film
like one thing that I really appreciate
about it is that it's completely like
devoid of any ulterior motive it's
strictly about like the well-being of
human beings and like this planet you
know and it doesn't I mean grant it
doesn't really make you feel like super
bad about your consumption like it's not
a guilt film it's just like the facts
kind of film and then it shows you how
you can do things better and that's what
I love because sometimes you can watch
these documentaries and they'll show you
like the very worst of everything and
that's pretty much all they'll show you
and you'll walk away saying okay like I
feel like I have a reason to do whatever
this documentary is telling me to do or
think however this person is telling me
to think or whatever but it doesn't
really like if you don't walk away with
tools or with like a different way of
life that you couldn't try then it's
kind of its kind of worthless you know
so it's it's amazing you have all these
people like in the film there's so many
bloggers it's crazy yeah it's definitely
it definitely showcases a wide variety
of different minimalists and I think
that's what's so nice about it like
there's no there's no one right we're to
do this there's so many different ways
but it's all em people connecting like
on that level and I just found it
totally and totally like breathtaking
and I really didn't expect it because
it's something that me and you both been
doing for quite a while you know we've
read all the minimalist books and saw
their stuffs nothing new to us and I was
really like surprised at how engaging
and Aamir's know it was and even like
even Ireland
from it mm-hmm yeah like it doesn't it's
not necessarily about how long you've
been like involved in the movement are
like been thinking this way like they
have something new to bring to the table
because like what they have to bring to
you is a feeling like a feeling that
things can be better and there's nothing
better than that feeling in my opinion I
was listening to this podcast last night
by Rob Bell and he's a really he's a
good he's a really great podcast and one
thing that he said he said have you ever
had somebody walk up to you and try and
convince you of their cause or somebody
trying to ask you to to donate money to
a cause or something like that if you
said no odds are they're coming from a
place like we have to do something about
this we have to do something about this
but he said how much would it change
your approach if they were to walk up to
you and be like look at what we can do
look at what we can do about this look
at how we can be a part of like a
massive beautiful change in the world
and that's such a more beautiful and
genuine and enticing place to come from
you know yeah yeah it is and I just I
love that it it made me really really
emotional and at first I didn't really
understand why I got like the end of the
movie I was just it was like happy tears
but you know in your eyes just like you
know like I'm not really entirely sure
what's going on here and I think it just
it's not very often that you watch
anything that I oh that you're a part of
anything that you really think like [ __ ]
this is gonna change the world like
that's what I actually thought when I
watched it because you know I think a
lot of people read books but the the
movie is gonna reach saw many more
people and this is this is just going to
explore and it's so exciting because I
thought about when I first found the
minimalist when I first found their blog
and
how that's probably like the one single
moment that I can say like really
changed my life like I wouldn't I
wouldn't be the same person I wouldn't
have the same values I wouldn't be
living my life in this way if it wasn't
for them and I know that so many people
are gonna watch this movie and they're
they're gonna have that moment and
they're gonna have that feeling and
that's just that's just incredible it's
such an incredible like movement to be a
part of and I'm I don't know like I'm
just so proud of how like how it was put
together and it was it was visually saw
so beautiful it was and I Fermi I think
the reason that I teared up I think is
because like the thing is is like weig
it should be a part of it you know what
I mean yeah I'm like I mean you you and
I like we kind of do like our own thing
like separate from the minimalist
obviously like Josh and I and our
friends and and you know everybody on
that team and a lot of people who are
also involved in the movement and I
think what it is is that like we're
involved in something that's like that's
bigger than ourselves and we felt we
felt the impact of it like on a very
personal level and I think that we all
intrinsically know what it can do on a
global scale you know and I understand
that like not everybody's going to buy
ethically and fast-fashion will exist
for a long time and like there's a lot
of changes that are yet to be made and
there's a lot of people that won't get
to see this film who really should but
it's such a step in like the right
direction because I mean like it's it
moves you so much and you think if it
moves us like it's gotta move other
people you know like we're all humans we
have emotions and yeah yeah it does and
I mean I've never watched anything with
noir eagle like it was such a humbling
thing to watch I was I was thinking
about it as I was watching it yesterday
and I thought I wonder how many hugs
there are like during the course of this
movie I would love for somebody there to
say it and count how many hugs they're
all because I just bet there's no other
documentary out there that has that like
it just it hits you right to the call
because it's it's all genuine and it's
all
a second is so simple and it's just
accessible to everyone like everyone can
live their own version of minimalism
whatever it means to them and it was it
was nice to see so many people on you
know so many different paths in life who
have that collective agreement of what
it means to live a well curated life and
what it means to live a good life yeah
it's so important that they brought that
in because I feel like a lot of people
tell me that like I feel like a lot of
people like tell me that like it's a
phase that like I'm not gonna you can't
be like oh you know I don't think it's a
phase you know when you get into
minimalism people are like oh well you
know that's okay that's cool for you and
and they kind of like treat it as like a
cute thing people always a hippie people
oh sit mates all that minimalist thing
that minimalist thing you're into is the
way yeah is that what like a person like
I'm some like angsty teenager that's
just decided to care about something for
a [ __ ] because it's cool I know I know
and it's so not that you know it's not
like I mean there's a difference between
like being passionate about owning less
stuff in living a well curated life and
like being a stupid hippie that's like
who needs jobs man just leaves you know
like it's a totally different thing I
mean it's like ad approaching life like
yes there may be some hippie qualities
to it because it's like yeah we should
love the earth but how is that like a
hippie thing I just don't understand
like the dirt on your feet provides
gravity so you don't fly off into space
and we're not supposed to love the earth
I just don't know yeah it's crazy but
it's nice they approach it in such a
like in such a logical manner that like
the naysayers to me it's like if you can
be a naysayer of like at least it has
value maybe you don't want to be a
minimalist that's totally cool like
nobody's gonna knock down your door I
mean if you want me to I can feel you
know a low if you want really
five hundred dollars plus a plane ticket
but I hope being down your gorge like
hey get rid of all your stuff but like
but that's I it was just beautiful it's
just good and they and it's like it's
really nice to have people representing
who you are in a way that like like
that's good like if somebody was to
watch the minimalism film and like oh
she's a minimalist I'd be like exactly
that's exactly what it is they present
it so properly yeah it's something that
you're you're proud to be a part of and
the way that that movie was portrayed
like there's just there's not one part
of it that I like turned off and I am
such a dear dreamer like I'm just
constantly dear dreaming so I find it
very difficult to watch anything or even
with books and that I go I have a very
short attention span and I was so glued
to it like it was just it was incredible
and I think that it really highlights in
not in a positive way but you know
consumerism like it it really sorry it
doesn't short in like a really really
like I'm nice sparing me so probably
here at all the way that that is
portrayed everyday do mistake yeah it's
not like a doomsday thing yeah but it's
it's also something that it's like no
like this is we all need to need to wake
up and understand and just be more
conscious of everything that we're doing
because like that's that's what's
important and I'm reading a book right
now and it's about fast fashion and it's
even you know I follow a lot of people
are an Instagram Hill were very in a you
know ik sustainable fashion which is
amazing it's great but it's it's still
very Morgan marketing and very
advertising and all like if you spend
100 100 pounds then you get this free
gift or blah blah blah and I just think
that it's still part of the problem like
fair enough when when it comes for you
needing to buy something if you can't
buy a second-hand buy it ethically great
but just because something's made
ethically like it still has an impact
from the environment like consumerism is
the problem you can't just switch the
goalposts and just because it's
so-called sustainable just means you can
go out and buy as much stuff as you want
no that's that's not the point it's
about being conscious of everything that
will buy and why will buy in it yeah
it's like it's the it's kind of like I
was actually looking for an article on
sustainable fashion yesterday for the
minimalist social media page and I found
it like I found a website and it was
this girl he was like a self compact
confessed alcoholic and she had seen the
light and but like the way she talked
about it was like so here's the
sustainable options and like it was kind
of like and I still love shopping like
sustainable shopping let's go to the
mall like yes stainable mall you know
and it's like that's not I think like
the hype is what people got a kind of
let go then it's hard it's like it's
hard to let go of the hype of
consumerism I mean like when you're a
kid you know like what are you hear you
hear like collect all 12 you know like
that's what they tell you about toys
it's just so it's built into us and they
addressed that too like in the film they
talked about how in the 90s America's
when Americans went on a buying spree
you know and they would purchase like a
bunch of shitty products from China I
think the the woman who spoke about it
was Juliette Shore she's in sociologist
and it and that was really as somebody
who was born in the 80s I have to say
that I don't remember a time where it
wasn't like that and it's really
fascinating to see somebody talk about
that and like in such an outlandish way
like look at what we've done it's like
well that's just life but you know when
you learn about it over time about how
it wasn't always that way
no yeah and I think something that
really scared me when I was watching it
was when they were talking about
advertising and specifically advertising
for children's toys and how they used to
market it to like parents or to to
mothers and then they switch the
goalposts because they realized it's a
lot easier just to go straight for the
kids in how like how prominent that is
in today's culture you know and the kids
are so innocent like how can you expect
a child to know any better than it just
fall for something like that like it's
just it's manipulation on just the
lowest lowest level and that just
terrifies me like the fact that that's
what our society is built on nowadays
and that's the kind of things that we've
got to do I mean there's a part where
Ryan says that he has to try and sell a
cell phone or a five-year-old like if
that if that is the world that we're
living in like I don't know anyone who
doesn't want that to change because it's
just it's not right like consumerism on
the whole is the problem it doesn't
matter how we made something is if
you're buying like 50 ethically made
tops each year or you buy one top from
fast-fashion
I you know it it's just yeah you can't
justify always better to buy one
fast-fashion top than it would be to buy
50 sustainably made time yeah
the would and I mean I know that I like
saying that kind of feels a little bit
weird you know but it's like at the same
time though like it's true you know it
just explain it but it's but the
children thing like advertising the
children it's so I mean like advertising
is mind control like straight up it's
true
like that's all it is it's just like
manipulating the mind and the difference
is is that like as adults you and I have
the capability to discern what these
advertisements mean but like kids most
of the time like don't have that yet and
to try to exercise that judicious
quality to know if something is
advertising or not not only as an adult
but as a child it can be really hard
because they slip it in and so good yeah
and we but we've built up this tolerance
for it though like a lot of adults don't
even know you know they're not aware of
how often they're manipulated HD it's
only when you
you look further in written look deeper
and with the year you realize what's
going on but it's it's really it's
really hard like it's a hard thing to
gauge and I think that that's what's
scary about it you know because you have
to constantly be thinking it because you
fighting against true or natural
instincts you know we have this urge to
accumulate that's like it's just part of
our the way we are and to to be aware of
that that is how you kind of put a
stopper in it you know but it's it's
still like I mean I can still find
myself you know sometimes being
attracted to something especially if
there's a if there's a magazine when I
go to the doctors and I'll have a flip
through it it's really hard not to be
drawn in by stuff like that and even is
minimalist its we're probably still you
know under a little bit of a spell in
some ways and it's it's that conscious
effort all the time if not you know I
don't need that like I really don't need
it that's why I think stuff like you
know putting yourself on a shopping ban
is a really good way forward at least to
just try and like curb any of those sort
of like emotions and feelin's yeah like
I think I totally agree with you you
need something to bring you back down to
earth and what's nice is I think that's
what this documentary does and like I
still feel like a draw draw to buy
things like if I if I stop at Target to
pick something up that like I wouldn't
expect to be like I had another store
which either like but I don't know for
some reason when I walk into target it's
like it's a nightmare my brain just like
it starts shutting down and I start
looking at like you know little like
animals that are like really kitschy
like statuettes and like these candles
and I start looking at their furniture
and I'm like what am i doing
you can look like I'm a minimalist what
if I do me like I gotta get the [ __ ] out
of target because it it just does
something to you that like when you walk
through you
like imagine what my house could look
like if I could just get that nightstand
okay hold on like this isn't this isn't
you don't need a nightstand just hang on
just back away from the home goods
section and I feel like you know
whatever I want to change something
about myself really badly I start
reading a lot about it and I start
watching like documentaries and
listening to podcasts because I feel
like anyone people are like oh I want to
get into this habit I want to get into
this habit it's like okay well like I
think that information will probably
convince you better than just telling
yourself you have to get into a habit oh
yeah [ __ ] I think especially the [ __ ]
its first apply that it they're pretty
scary it's something that can definitely
like terrify you in a change but I think
you know when you're talking about
target like at least you're aware when
you walk in that shop you know like
you're aware of what's going on I think
it's it it's the ethical stuff like we
went at the weekend cuz we had one nice
weekend here it was it was amazing it
was sunny for all of like two or three
hours and I with shops to buy some
natural Sun Sun cream because I didn't
have any in a minute and so went to this
place which why they want a new marriage
across re-answer which by the way
sunscreen causes cancer yeah well
exactly you get traditional sunscreens
but I've gotten burnt like the weekend
before hiking and I've got a weddin to
gordo so I really need it even out we
t-shirt timelines no well I know I mean
I know you like I know you're like you
know I knew I knew you were buying that
stuff I wouldn't have it no I wouldn't
have been like by the way Melissa but no
but like it's you know no you know you
know that but it's for other people who
don't do that cuz I didn't know that and
I was like oh I'm gonna put on sunscreen
so I don't get cancer look at all the
cancer-causing chemicals inside of this
little bottle yeah that's that's another
freaky saying you know what you don't
want you don't know what what was
slathered on our bodies you don't know
what you buy in but anyway I went to
this store over here and it's called
Holland and Barrett and it's all like
natural and organic so went and we
bought em Sun cream and then I just
started looking at the essential oil
and then some of the other natural
beauty products and it was so easy to
get like drawn in because I think no
this this is really good for you though
like this is good stuff
you know it's its natural its organic
yeah but it's still like consumed and I
do really need it you know and it's it's
really hard because I think that it can
be used as a marketing ploy you know
it's like a guilt-free purchase I think
oh but this is natural yeah but okay but
do you need it like do you need three
natural mascaras or is that less Esav
you know like I think that that's that's
the new demon that's coming up and that
that's something that we've got to be
aware of because I see it way too often
on Instagram and you walk into shops
like that and even I'm easily swayed and
I've been a minimalist now for like two
and a half years but you know I'm aware
when I walk in supermarkets that that's
what's happening but when I walk in
these like natural herbal shops I just
get so absorbed in it and that's that's
what can be dangerous and it's good to
know like what your what your kryptonite
is you know like it's good to know like
what your thing is that you're like you
know like I walk into Best Buy I'm gonna
have to do some fighting and that's I
mean it's it's kind of what's nice about
buying online even though like there's a
whole nother gamut of things that you
can like be sucked into it's it's
totally different than being in person
because being in person you can hold the
object and mm-hmm if you look at like
with the way they set up like Apple
stores the reason they set it up the way
that they do is they have like all of
these all of these tables and they have
you know the phones out and you can pick
them up and you can touch them and
they've done studies and they've figured
out that if you touch something and if
you hold something you've already become
attached to it more so than if you
haven't touched something before so like
they're increasing your attachment I
know it's crazy like they're increasing
your desire to like own that thing like
I'm just i allowing you to touch it I
mean that's scary
it's definitely terrifying because it's
so subtle
you know these people who advertise like
they know their stuff you know and it's
a lot of it is science like they know
the way that your brain works and they
know what's gonna make you want to buy
something I don't know about you but
that that really scares me and it scares
me that we use in that tool to get
people to buy stuff you know like all
all these steps that we've taken in
science and how now it's being
manipulated in that salt way like that
makes me kind of sad like I think that
because you because with Tristan
you know you trust the government
interest these companies because you
think that they've got your best
interests at heart
you'd like to think that and it's just
not the case
no they like the government or the
companies like I honestly think like if
you think that like the government or
like any corporation has your best
interest at heart no like I'm sorry but
that's not like unfortunately how the
world works and what's really nice about
like I think the film overall too is
that it brings it back to you you know
like we can try we can all try and like
jump over these barriers and try and
like legislate all of this stuff and
like we can really try to do all of
these things and like go through the
quote-unquote man you know to try and
accomplish like a less consumeristic
society or whatever have more
sustainable shopping but like what I
really like is like the film brings it
back to you yeah and they say this is
your responsibility like you might be a
victim in its sense that advertisers
have like gone through and grabbed onto
your mammalian brain and twisted your
desires to be something that feeds their
needs and their wallets but no matter if
they it's their fault or not fault is
not the issue and being a victim isn't
going to get us anywhere so stop buying
so much [ __ ] and start living
meaningfully and really start paying
attention to what is going on around you
and I
say like the fact that I walked out like
I guess I mean the first time I saw it I
saw it in Los Angeles at a festival and
I think first time I walked out of that
film I didn't feel like a victim I felt
powerful and like there's nothing better
that you can do to encourage somebody
like in a movement than to empower them
to let them know that they can make a
difference and it's not by spending
money yeah because it's it's so it's
easily accessible to everybody like
anyone can do this like that is
incredible and you're right
you walk I ever thinking okay how am I
gonna change me life you know how has
this impacted me because I think it
impacted in a really really big way like
the way that they put the noise of
consumerism against you know the the
peacefulness and people talking about
how amazing minimalism is like I just I
couldn't think of any other better way
for it to be put across and what's great
is that some of the stuff that I noticed
was that you know it's not all in bear
rooms you know you've got these people
who you know believe in minimalism even
if they don't call at that and you know
some of the scientists especially had
you know I get corners full of books if
you're a minimalist you can still own a
lot of books like minimalism is about
you and it's about you getting that use
of stuff you know like not by instead of
frivolously and I thought that that was
portrayed really nicely and like just
kind of just a how like lovely was lay
over about her all right when he was
like this is like a really good plague
oh he's so lovely he's just like he
seems so agreeable yeah and like just
like so easy to talk to yeah but like
you know a lot of these people do like
it's and that's what's nice is I don't I
don't feel like I don't feel like they
are trying to convince me of anything
because the thing is is the evidence of
like this of like this world of
advertising and consumerism like we
don't need to see like we don't need to
see that you know like we're subjected
to it on a daily basis and even
they do show some images of like Black
Friday which I do think is really
important regardless like they know that
the evidence is right in front of us and
it's more so about getting past it but I
do want to talk about the Black Friday
stuff because like man I was wildly I
already had one part I felt like I felt
like it it was like how can this not be
a mental illness like you're laying on
the ground fighting over a box and
you're in your mid-40s
how can you not have a mental illness
commander he gave me a woman that was
screamin like what are you doing like
I'm so scared like you're attacking me
and I was like oh god I don't even think
he's in the boxes no no I it was like
it's just it's crazy
and but I know that's not everybody but
you gotta hit that wall like you cop you
gotta see that other end of the spectrum
mm-hmm yes well in juxtapose that with
like minimalism to really get a full
understanding of like where you can meet
in the middle or closer to minimalism
because it's better anyways yeah because
that's the extreme but everyone falls on
a level of the spectrum you know so like
how how often away kill you've just
walking in and picking something up and
just buying it kind of mindlessly you
know like that's on like a ridiculously
extreme level but I think that
everyone's guilty of that at certain
points in their life probably more than
most of us would like to admit and
that's what that's what's scary about it
you know because I think that I think
there was some like imagery for my Times
Square and stuff and we are just
bombarded like there was so much noise
like the noise is constant and it was
like it I mean ACK I can't go in the
shopping centers I just I really feel
anxious shopping and being in that sort
of environment because everything tells
you that you are not enough you know you
are not good enough you are not thin
enough you're not pretty enough you know
like and it's exhausting I feel like
when you're in that sort of lifestyle
it's just a constant battle and then
when you saw the elements of minimalism
it just seemed so like peaceful and I
just thought you know this is
this is the part of minimalism that I
love and I think that it's really hard
to articulate of the people like how
good it feels and I think that the movie
just it's shorter
saw so well and make you say like all
the people in it we're so empowered by
it and you feel empowered just watching
it because you know that it's something
that you can go home as soon as you've
watched the movie and you can change
your life like you can change the way
that you think and you don't have to you
don't like have to be on this like
roller coaster of consumerism you can
choose something more peaceful and just
more in harmony with the earth because
like God were absolutely destroying it
and it's nice to think there's a big
movement of people that you know like
trying to protect it and try and like
live alongside it and balance that yeah
and I want to I want to say to back to
the New York scene that you're talking
about what about those bags like the
people were walking around with these
bags and they said like believe on the
side and it was like in this really
whimsical lettering that looked like
Santa could have written it and like
there were these red bags and it was
just so like I liked when I saw the word
like believe like on the side of a
shopping bag that was like I thought
that was a really incredible like moment
because what it was
say it like you should believe what's in
this bag like this bag is gonna make you
know it's labeling something what's in
this bag is going to change your life
and you're going to feel better and
you're going to be more beautiful and
all it's kind of why I like living in
Hawaii cuz nobody gets dressed in the
morning it seems like everybody wakes up
but they just walk out of the house like
wearing whatever they have probably not
showered in three days cuz look a hippy
colony nice I like that I like that
imagery that you've left me with there
maybe I'll move to Hawaii
no but you you right though and it's aw
it's so subtle it's so manipulative I
believe oh like [ __ ]
I call [ __ ] I would love to just
visit em if anyone's ever watched an
Idiot Abroad
Carl pilling unit karl Pilkington get
asked what superhero he would want to be
like what sort of superpower he would
want and he said he'd want to be
[ __ ] man and I just think I would
love that
like just wandering around what it's
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] because a lot of it is
like a lot of the stuff that we consume
that we read that we get told by
companies and government it's the
majority of it's [ __ ]
like it's all just here you see and
people talk an absolute shite and it was
nice torture movie that he can believe
what they see and you know what they're
not trying to sell you something they're
not there's no ulterior motives like
it's just like a genuine hope for the
well-being of other people and like
empowering them in that way I think
that's incredible yeah and they also one
thing that's really nice about the film
is they talk about the how versus why or
the why versus how rather like they they
talk about the why you should do it as
opposed like you know here's like a good
way to declutter your closet you know
it's like every time I see an article or
a blog post like that I want to just
throw up in my mouth because it's just
so it doesn't like it doesn't give you
anything like you could literally just
take all of those things and just throw
it in a bag and just like give it to
Goodwill and I know goodwill isn't the
best company in the world but like you
could do that and that's like really
simple but it's not about that and I
think what's nice is like because they
go into the why they take it to a
different point
it's not about decluttering your closet
it's about a new life philosophy where
you get to be in charge of where your
money goes and you get to decide how
other companies and other people affect
you and your decisions to spend the
money that you have worked for with the
time that you had on this earth and it's
like that's what it's about and man like
there was that one point where [ __ ] I'm
forgetting his name he's a he's a
stockbroker aid
AJ Leone was it yes AJ Leon like the
point where he talks about how his like
he was going to he received he was going
to be in a position and he was going to
receive a raise and he realized like
that he couldn't like walk away from
that large sum of money yeah and and how
he didn't envy his boss's life it was
like I man like that part I just like my
heart just like stop so when I watch
that because I I feel like there's so
many people that like are trading so
much of their lives for the money
yeah and they want to just like get to a
point you know like I want to just get
to this point and I just want to get
like you know my head above water and
it's like do like you don't have to keep
punch riding water you can just float
and it would all be okay and you can
like enjoy the world around you without
having accomplished X Y & Z yeah but
what we don't get told anything
different you know success is for a lot
of people how much money they're making
and that's really really sad like that
sad that that's what we're judging
things are nothing that would we've got
really confused between happiness and
money you know we think that you have
you have to be earning a certain amount
of money to be happy and that being rich
means that you're happy and it's just
it's or not the kids and I think that
the majority of the time it's the
opposite like I've been at Ireland with
people who just have nothing like
they're really they don't have anything
and they are so much happier than we are
it's also so much happier and they have
nothing like it's it's not about money
it's about connecting with people and
it's about using your talents to do and
be to be a power of something good in
the world like that's what it's about
and I think that that's what was really
nice because it was about the connection
you know was about connecting with other
people and that's what's been amazing I
could become an anomalous
meetin other people who are minimalist
because like they're all such genuine
lovely people you know in their own
little wares and it's just it's so
incredible to be a part of I just I
couldn't see anything else like nicer
about it and what I really liked as well
was you know Josh and Ryan kind of sunk
down right into their depth so going
into that past and some of the stuff
that they'd been through and I think
that that that really hit me hard you
know because I think that you can look
at people's lives from the outside and
think oh everything's perfect and I
think that the had a call from Jim
Carrey on saying that they wanted
everyone to be rich and famous
to realize that's not the answer and
somebody said like oh yeah well like
that's great for Jim Carrey to say yeah
but like he's the only one who can say
that and it's nice to be able to to
watch something and think that you know
you can go through all this [ __ ] and you
can you can come out the other side and
you can still make something good of it
in the pursuit of money and the pursuit
of any kind of like status like that
it's not it's not gonna make you happy
it's not gonna make you more secure like
the only way to do that is to consume
and consume less and live within your
own means and like they're like there's
a security and that like there's a
security and knowing that you can be
okay like that you can feel satisfied
without other people supplying that
satisfaction or without paying other
people yeah like if you like I mean you
can feel satisfied without buying a
bunch of [ __ ] like you feel acity to do
that because I mean you get you get the
initial like hi like I always say people
who are driving around in ridiculously
nice cars or who live in really big
houses and I just think God how stressed
you must be all the time like I don't
like parking in car parks cuz like
sometimes I get stressed and I'm gonna
like bump me chorus and think and my car
isn't even worth that much like I think
if I was driving around in a really nice
car I'd just be constantly worried about
it like when you're all really nice
stuff it's like people who have like the
newest it bag or the newest I for
I mean I've got an iPhone but if it's
something that you know you constantly
buy in the newest thing I just think it
stresses you out like for the first few
months when I get like something new I'm
just like paranoid about it I'm like oh
god what if I like dropped me falling in
the toilet or what if I'd like crash me
car and smash it up because you've spent
so much money on it they give invested
in it and it just becomes this worry it
just becomes this weird on your
shoulders and actually on and less and
having less stuff to worry about is so
much better than the tiny little bit of
gratification you get from like spending
money and getting something that you
want yeah it's so weird like that that
we can take like the concept of time
that we've spent like we can take time
and we can purchase a thing with it and
that thing that we purchase people don't
think about that amount of time and the
thing is is like I feel like if you like
the thought process amongst a lot of us
it's like if I spent a lot of time to
earn that money to acquire that thing
that thing is more time and like I'm
just trying to acquire more time and
like I'm just trying to convince myself
that that I'm supposed to be like that
I'm gonna be here forever you know and I
really think that a lot of this is about
like not facing our mortality - to be
honest with you like that's really what
I think a lot of this like consumeristic
[ __ ] is about it just it seems to me
like we're trying to we're trying to
avoid or a kind of difficult truth by
purchasing a feeling yeah and and
instead of trying to dig deeper and like
and kind of sit with that you know like
and like rest with that and be okay with
that and understand that like you can't
just like purchase like eternal fame and
even if you do purchase eternal fame the
fame will outlive you and you won't even
be there to experience it
yeah that is so true I think I think
what scary is how insidious a problem
advertised and has become you know even
like you are you are manipulated so many
times that you don't even realize it's
even stuff like Instagram you know like
now company sponsor ordinary people or
you know like quote-unquote ordinary
people like bloggers and different
people you know to sell their products
and you don't even realize that you that
that's being sold here because it's just
whoever posting a picture of them with a
protein shake that's been sponsored and
they've been told exactly how to take
that picture what time they're to put it
out what what to say what caption to put
underneath it and that's that's where
people have to get their backs up you
know because yeah like when you walk in
a shopping center you know you know that
people advertise and people are trying
to get you to spend money what you don't
realize is when you're going through
your facebook feed or your Instagram
feed and you see celebrities or even I
mean it's not even celebrities now it is
there is it it's just German that girl
quit social media yeah something I think
it started like it starts the II like I
don't know like essa or something like
that I'm talking about is that a San
Antonio maybe yes Antonio that's she
yeah she quit social media obviously
because you know it's it's pretty
narcissistic on that but she had
thousands of followers though and she's
learning false life hundreds or she like
yeah yeah and she like created this
false life of her like living lavishly
and she would just get dressed for all
these Instagram posts and then she kind
of had this moment where she realized
that she was manipulating like masses
amount of people and like they didn't
know that it was advertising and she
quit social media and like stopped
wearing makeup and like yeah I think
she's like 18 yeah I was so stupid at 18
smart choices
yeah definitely but it's it's so nice to
see somebody stepping back from that but
the problem is that she ended up I think
she started I think she got her
Instagram back some somehow she shared
some of the four tours the cheat taken
during the course of her being on
Instagram and what had actually happened
saw her drink in a green smoothie Austin
link in it it would have been a
sponsorship from I don't know fake
whoever and you would never you would
never have known that just flicking
through like you would have thought all
green smoothie you know it is quite fun
see green smoothie oh what's that
company and you don't even realize that
that company is paying that person a
hell of a lot of money to manipulate you
it's so subtle and I think that's you
know a big reason why the minimalists
you know don't believe in advertisements
and and we dawned because I don't think
there's any good way to sell something
you know like a product should just
stand on its own like it's you shouldn't
need to be manipulated to buy something
yeah and like I don't like I don't think
like do you really want to convince I
don't know I don't know if I don't want
it like if I had a product I don't know
if I'd want to do very much convincing
for them to purchase it anyways because
it's like I've been sucks they've laid
it on themselves you know it's like well
be like you chose to buy this this is
kind of like you know it's kind of like
the podcast it's like well like it's
free and it's your choice to listen to
it so I like I don't think I'd ever want
like force anybody or manipulate anybody
into listening to it no definitely not
and that's that's what's nice because
going back to the movie it just it
poetry is it in such a nice light and
that they've got that like the tiny
house movement and that that is
something that I mean it's extremely
radical but but you know with the space
that we're all taking up nowadays in the
amount of rooms that we have in our
houses that we don't even use and it's
it's about you know like being
economical in everywhere you live
life you know and trying to take up you
know as least fast as you can and just
being more considerate of like the
environment and all sort to yourself
because at the root of this is the fact
that consumers and doesn't make you
happy it doesn't matter how many things
you buy you know like spend your money
on experiences don't build a house full
of [ __ ] and expect that to make you
happy because it just warned and there's
there's nothing against that but and I
mean I'm someone who like I did love
fashion and I still love clothing but I
don't really love fashion because it's
just it's so manipulative and it I think
that what could be used as a tool to
empower people is used is a way of just
making shitloads of money and that's
that's sad you know it it's sad that we
that there's so many people benefiting
from it like all these corporations and
companies selling all this [ __ ] that we
don't need like it's crazy yeah it in
like we have to realize that like the
purpose isn't to make us happy the
purpose is to make them money which they
think will make them happy so as long as
we realize like as long as we understand
the motive then like we're like we're in
good hands and I think that's that's
really what this film does is it it puts
into perspective who's doing what why
they're doing it and how you can change
things and I mean really like the entire
film is I think part of the reason
personally that I wasn't like I didn't
get bored at any time is because they
really they make it a story but really
three stories are happening in this film
the first story is of like people like
Josh and Ryan and other people in the
film you know like Joshua Becker and
Cortney Carver and it's the story of
their lives and like how minimalism has
impacted them personally and then it's
about like also like economists and
sociologists since
ecologist sand all these people who are
also explaining to you what advertising
and what consumerism is doing to you and
then the third story I think is is
environmentally what we are doing to the
planet so it goes between those three
stories and I think it keeps you
interested because you're not just
staying with somebody else's story
you're not just experiencing what's
being done to you and you're not just
experiencing what you are doing to the
planet but you're understanding all
three in a very strong cohesive way and
it's a very linear it's a very linear
storyline but it takes you so many
different places from in so many
different perspectives and I think
there's nothing like having that
understanding like if you want to create
a habit or change your life there's
nothing better than just like taking
time to inform yourself on the matter
and then you can convince yourself but
like you don't know the facts to do so
you're not going to be able to force
yourself into like a habit you know of
getting rid of stuff you have to you
have to arm yourself with knowledge and
make yourself feel powerful yeah and I
think that what was really nice for me
is the fact that you know created a
society where there's not a lot of trust
like people don't feel like they can
trust of the people and they don't
protect that interest the government or
pretty much anyone who rules a big part
of their lives and it's nice to watch a
movie like that and watch all these
genuine people and to be able to put
your trust in somebody in in these
people in tune or that it's well-placed
you know it does it there's a few
moments in the movie where they go and
do a book signing and nobody would sure
but I would got to do like oh like one
person show up and they've got to do a
talk and then only be a handful of
people they're like they're doing it for
the love of it like they genuinely want
to spread this message whether it's like
one person whether it's a few million
people which is like definitely where
this is going
that's that's genuine you know and that
is that's all powerful it's nice to know
that
these people I'm just trying to like
scam you out of money they like they
genuinely want the best for everyone in
the world and I think that that's just
amazing yeah
there's no those no ulterior motives are
not trying to sell you anything if they
don't want anything from you
like and that's awesome if you like yeah
it's awesome it's an amazing film so if
you guys if you guys would like to see
it you can go to minimalism film comm
and there you can you can like find a
local theater I think it's playing in
theatres your theater is until late June
and if you go to minimalism or the
minimalist calm slash order then you can
order the film on Vimeo which it's a
pre-order so after you purchase the film
it will be released to you on August 2nd
and coming along with the with that
purchase is also six hours of bonus
footage which like I'm excited about I
they're like there's like we all
collectively like myself Marla and Josh
Sarris and Dave Philippe all of them
from Spira media and Josh and Ryan and
everybody that's on the team
Sean Harding and Matt Dave Ella we all
like read books by all these people that
are involved in the film and I'm like
I'm so excited to see like what those
questions are and how they went because
it's just like they really I mean they
really dug deep and found like the
really really good people that know a
lot about these topics and it's I mean
it's gonna be really fascinating and
what's really cool is the minimalist
podcast just released today and I posted
the like I posted when there was a new
essay so last night at like 12:30 I got
online to post in USA for the minimalist
like oh my gosh they're releasing some
of the bonus footage on their podcast so
I think it's uh I I don't know what the
URL is but the minimalist most recent
podcast it's titled minimalism you can
go there and you can listen to that some
of that bonus footage well now I've got
something oh I feel finished recording
it's quite bad but I would
I would love to just sit and watch the
excel footage so in that footage are
they interviewing like some of the
people who are in the movie does it just
go into more depth yeah yeah it goes
into more depth because of course like
in the film they have to like you know
they can only include like clips but
obviously there's still like it's a
treasure trove of knowledge you know
it's still a goldmine there's still like
plenty of people that are really like
well-versed and and all of these all of
these feels God so then that's gonna be
incredible too like I'm gonna be sore
bad I'm gonna buy some food I'm gonna
sit in all day and watch interviews
about minimalism so you yeah so you can
and so it's in theaters May 24th which
is while we're recording today and I'm
honestly like thinking about like I'm
honestly just thinking about posting see
it podcast today like as soon as I have
it edited just having it go up even
though like we're a day late it's like
you know what I know what's minimalism
film day we got to do it yeah I think so
jinke in do it I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try to do it just suddenly the audio ace
happen I'll try and edit it and get it
all up there like ASA yeah because like
this is important stuff like just flat
out this is really important stuff and
it's exciting so yeah I just I'm really
it's a good team I'm so proud of
everybody they all did an amazing job
and man like if you guys are ready to
like change your life and and think
about the world differently or you know
even if you've already been invested in
minimalism for a while I can listen I
have which really isn't that long in the
grand scheme of things but it's a good
amount of time no matter where you're at
it's it's always good to learn more
about the world around you and they do a
great job of that yeah I'm so excited to
be able to share this with like people
like me dad and friends you know who if
I'd given them the book the wouldn't
they wouldn't have read it but I know
with this movie I'm gonna be able to
show them it and they're gonna
understand that really excites me yeah
that's I mean it because like
don't really read books and honestly
gifting somebody a book is like hey I'm
taking eight hours like here you go
like now make sure that you dedicate
like several hours because I'm gonna ask
you questions write different you can
like watch it with them and like it's
entertaining people are always looking
for like I don't know like good things
to watch it seems to me like there's
like you know there can be like some
really [ __ ] TV shows and movies out
there and this just doesn't fall under
that category able to come back to you
know because I mean if not like you
don't fall off the wagon but everyone
has those moments you know away like
well like what's going on I feel a
little bit disconnected again and it's
nice to be able to watch something like
that and to reacquaint yourself with you
know all the reasons why you fell in
love with minimalism and why you want to
live this life yeah it's important to
have a reminder because sometimes like
you know you get so immersed in life
that you can kind of lose sight of like
what's important no matter who you are
you know and like that's a really
important thing to keep in mind and and
that's why that's one of the reasons why
this film is so good and I can't wait to
watch it
yes no it definitely definitely is and I
want to say that one thing to the
soundtrack amazing spectacular they're
really used music well like some of the
tense music I can feel a field in me
chest I really was like yeah you know
one that had this when they had the
stuff fun about like Black Friday and
stuff like whoa yeah like visually as
well like it's so beautiful that that
part where josh is stunned and I'm
guessing it's in a desert somewhere oh
yeah that's that's the that's the salt
flat oh my god in Salt Lake or not in
Salt Lake in Utah it's outside of Salt
Lake and it's like this it's like this
expansive like I mean it's not I mean I
don't know if it
necessarily a desert but like it's just
it's completely flat it doesn't really
rain that much and it like it's just
amazing it's like you can look down at
your reflection it's insanely beautiful
and I just thought yeah yeah Wow yeah
and there the band is we and it's it's
two guys named drew and Nate and I'm we
might be releasing it
we might be releasing the soundtrack so
man I like keep your eyes open for that
because that one I am not gonna lie I
have the soundtrack and I've been mild
like this team deserves it hard yeah
team deserves it hard well thank you
guys so much for listening this week it
was such a pleasure to talk about this
film and like to just banter back and
forth about it and again if you want to
learn more you can go to minimalism film
comm and there you can either you can
find a theater in your area that might
be playing the film if it's not playing
in your area if you're in the United
States you can request the film to be in
your area and you can get the film to
play it's also playing in Canada and
then the world ride ride release is
August 2nd where you can order it on on
Vimeo and you can't just go to
minimalist calm slash order and there
you can purchase it for 20 bucks not so
bad
oh I'm excited and also I just wanted to
say a big thank you as well because if
you think in whoa
Melissa's audio is insanely clear oh
yeah is really does it feel like
Melissa's behind me that's cuz I
actually I'm no but I just want to say
it like a really huge thank you to all
the people who have donated to us and
supported us because we're finally
invested in it decent microphone so you
don't have to deal with static and I'm
really hoping that I've got all the
settings right because those
there's a lot of stuff going on with
this one so I'm probably saying thank
you and a miss I'm like [ __ ] on your end
I really hope it doesn't but yes thank
you so much to all the people who've
donated and all the people who have
listened to us and I think will comment
at the end of this season now so next
season we hopefully will be shit-hot
audio wise even more so than this time
yeah hopefully well I know I'm like
crossing my fingers like maybe we'll get
two microphones maybe look at see
microphones it's hard it's like
expensive but it's just not worth it
when you hear that that audio quality
doesn't ring through your ears
it is definitely and if you would like
to contribute again to us you can do so
because we're still we still need to buy
Jess nice new my performance I know but
you should like hey guys I need a new
microphone I'll just like cover up my
like I'll decrease the quality goes on
to entice yes you can go to the mind
Palace podcast comScore at the bottom
and you can donate it to us there and
you can now work with us too can't you
dress yes you can
yeah if you'd like to work with Melissa
you can go to the mind Palace
podcast.com slash cure rates or if you
would like to cultivate your passion you
can go to with me and go through the
mind Palace podcast comm slash cultivate
and yeah we're here to help you and
we're here to get involved and help you
along your your journey into getting
your capsule wardrobe properly in order
and cultivating a meaningful passion
yeah it's been exciting all right guys
well thank you so much for listening and
have a wonderful Levi guys
if I was faced inside my philosophy
in place something so familiar so far to
get to
but say my dear for me picture of myself
like things that
you just feel
so there